poids échelle ou réhausseur le bottin un
annuaire téléphonique papiers aux
multiples fonctions depuis 1880 ses
enfants le trouvais même très
divertissant 1985 cochon kaki qui
renforceront la cloche lacourte
la cuisse des utilités diverses qui
n'empêcheront pas le beau temps d'être
plusieurs fois menacé de disparition
exemple en 1979 l'annuaire téléphonique
électronique pesait alors une arrivée
remarquée pour ce journaliste cette
évolution technologique signait l'arrêt
de mort du bon vieil annuaire papier
d'ici à une dizaine d'années les abonnés
du téléphone en france n'auront plus
besoin de ceux ci à savoir l'annuaire
téléphonique traditionnel qui présente
beaucoup d'inconvénients
il est lourd mal pratique rarement un
jour autre concurrent du gotha en 1981
l'annuaire sur micro pis principal atout
sa légèreté grâce à cet appareil vous
pourrez déchiffrer tous les numéros de
téléphone répertoriés sur ses fiches
une fiche reproduit au minimum 100 pages
de l'annuaire papier mais le beau temps
n'avait pas dit son dernier mot
pour l'édition 83 une version réduite et
allégée étaient proposés aux abonnés un
argument de poids
vous avez choisi le petit pourquoi parce
qu'il est mignon mignon jusqu'à
l'arrivée d'internet à la fin des années
90 le coup de grâce pour le beau temps
voici le premier annuaire sur internet
son nom
les pages humain la différence c'est que
l'ordinateur ne se contente pas de vous
donner le numéro 10 chiffres d'un simple
clic de souris l'information vous est
livré en images le beau temps remplacé
par l'informatique
en 2003 ce directeur d' agences des
pages on ne voulait toujours pas y
croire
on a toujours dit le zéro papier serait
remplacé par l'informatique c'est pas
vrai les gens se servent de plus en plus
du papier l'informatique ne le
remplacera jamais et pourtant après cent
trente neuf ans de bons et loyaux
services le beau temps tire
définitivement sa révérence
[Musique]